bruno pomart ans pour ma ancien policier
du raid bruno pomart merci d'être avec
nous en direction arte france on a vu à
l'instant à nice un groupe de
l'identifier en tout cas comme étant des
patriotes venir rendre hommage à ces
trois personnes tuées par l'attentât est
ce que il y à une crainte aujourd'hui
sur le territoire français de
groupuscules d'autodéfense qui
finalement appellerait à combattre sur
le territoire français à se faire
justice eux mêmes
est ce que c'est un risque qui a pu être
identifiée ou qui pourraient exister sur
le sol français
écoutez ça serait la prochaine étape
effectivement il faut il faut se garder
surtout que ça existe évidemment parce
que ce que souhaite ces individus c'est
l'un s'est justement que les communautés
les groupes d'opposition ou auto
évidemment ce sera entre les uns dans
les autres et tout simplement c'est
déstabiliser encore une fois la société
et si on arrivait à ça ça veut dire que
ces fondamentalistes
or ou gagner alors on va revenir sur
cette attaque ce matin attaques
terribles attentats à l'église notre
dame de l'assomption à nice ce sont des
policiers municipaux des policiers
nationaux donc de vos anciens collègues
qui sont intervenus aujourd'hui comment
qu'est ce qu'on leur dit quelles sont
les consignes face à une telle situation
il ya d'abord nos policiers on l'a vu
sont intervenus avec beaucoup
d'efficacité
effectivement après l'événement mais je
pense qu'ils ont limité peut être une
tuerie qui aurait pu être une tuerie
beaucoup plus importante et je crois ce
qu'on peut voir encore aujourd'hui c'est
que nos policiers sont encore devant ces
scènes terribles de violence et ils sont
surtout efficace investisseurs tel
terreau venu quasiment dans la minute
qui a suivi l'attentât
avec le soutien de la police nationale
évidemment puisque ce sont les policiers
municipaux qui sont intervenus la police
nationale et leur aide évidemment le
groupe d'intervention qui est une unité
locale également qui existe à nice qui
sont intervenues ensuite pour soutenir
évidemment la police municipale il ya eu
un travail très fort de la part des
policiers et qui sont évidemment très
très sollicités vous en doutez bien par
rapport à tout ce qui se passe
actuellement
et tous les événements qu'on a vu dans
l'après midi que s'il ya d'autres
événements qui ont eu lieu à avignon et
à lyon parce qu'on se souvient il ya
quelques années le raid ou encore le
gign intervenait sur des théories sur
des prises d'otages
finalement les modes opératoires ont
complètement évolué et c'est le policier
de terrain qui va être en première ligne
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est formé pour
ça ou est-ce qu'il est fort mais
différemment
écoutez des primes aux intervenants ce
qu'on appelle les prix n'ont été
annoncés ce sont les policiers que vous
voyez tous les jours dans la rue
évidemment on des consignes sont sont
briefés sont entraînés évidemment pour
être capable de réagir à ce type de
situation parce que c'est nouveau depuis
quelques années mais ça reste ça reste
nouveau dans notre répertoire
je dirais donc effectivement ils sont
ils sont formés et sensibilisés et ceux
qui étaient pourtant devoir c'est que
évidemment la police est quand même à
évoluer dans les méthodes puisque depuis
2000 15 depuis les attentats de 2015 il
faut savoir que vous avez des unités du
raid et du gign qui sont dans les
régions pré incas venir évidemment il ya
soutenir la police locale d'opium
travail qui a été fait pour répondre à
ces faits de terrorisme qui sont
difficilement décelables vous en doutez
bien même si les services et des
renseignements on a déjà et si les
enseignements territoriaux font un
travail formidable pour un tig et nombre
de nombre d'attentats terroristes qui
ont été déjoués d'ailleurs néanmoins
baer voyez ce qu'on voit avec ces
terroristes locaux ce qu on dit qu'ils
sont très difficilement identifiable
pour le service est qui et qui fait que
benno nos services je dirais de
terribles de tous les jours la police
nationale qui est sur le terrain dans
son sens y intervenir le plus rapidement
possible avec malheureusement les les
les dégâts que cela me cause et ses
terroristes low cost comme vous les
appelez est ce qu'il y aura des choses à
mettre en place justement pour essayer
qu'il ne passe pas à travers les mailles
du filet ou alors c'est vraiment
particulièrement compliqué on ne peut
rien faire
à écouter c'est terrible de dire c'est
très très compliqué pour les services de
renseignement qui travaillait au jour le
jour ce que nous assurer qu'il faut un
travail formidable ils ont déjoué nombre
d'attentats depuis le début de l'année
donc ce sont des gens très
opérationnelle le problème c'est que là
la nébuleuse terroriste qui présente sur
notre notre territoire est important
avec des éléments qui sont comment dire
impalpable pour la police elles et qu'on
peut
qu'on peut être qu'apple est parfois je
dirais presque avec un peu de chance
mais comme on l'a vu là comme on l'a vu
sur le sur le professeur même s'il y
avait des renseignements c'est compliqué
de savoir à quel moment ces gens là vont
passer à l'action
et ça c'est une vraie complicité pour
les services de l'ordre en tout cas le
plan vigipirate porter au niveau urgence
attentat sur l'ensemble du territoire
le président humaine macron annonce le
passage de 3000 à 7000 militaires pour
l'opération sentinelle c'est suffisant
selon vous écoutez c'est déjà une
avancée pour sécuriser
évidemment les lieux de culte et l'autre
bien qu on croit pas sécuriser tous les
lieux de culte vous doutez bien qu'il ya
des centaines et des milliers de
l'église donc ce n'est pas possible si
on compte les les mosquées également
c'est pas possible
donc c'est une avance effectivement en
terme de sécurité et je pense qu'on va
devoir prendre conscience de la
nécessité de solliciter peut-être des
sociétés privées de sécurité pour
pouvoir aider la police nationale à
faire de la du travail de sécurisation
sur le terrain parce que je pense que
nos policiers vont avoir beaucoup de mal
à assurer toutes ces émissions puisque
je vous rappelle qu'il ya également le
leur confinement qui est en jeu à partir
de ce soir alors un nouveau conseil de
défense aura lieu demain matin à
l'elysée présidée par emmanuel macron
qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre selon
vous écoutez c'est la coordination de
l'ensemble des services mais ça c'est
une classique et je pense de la police
est avec les services de renseignement
que je disais de gendarmerie de police
et autres des soutiens évidemment au
service santé parce qu'on a deux jeunes
services de santé lorsqu'il ya des
opérations paris en terme psychologique
en termes d' aide aux gens qui ont été
victimes donc il ya un gros travail de
coordination d'ensemble pour mettre tout
le monde je dirais impression pour être
opérationnels au maximum sur le terrain
dans les jours qui vont suivre parce que
la situation est quand même très tendu
un grand merci bruno pomart d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions
directes eurent été francs